right there in Washington a busy day
here in the nation's capital several
major stories happening here but we
begin tonight in South Florida there has
been a shooting at a high school in
parkland north of Miami and there are
reports of injuries and what the school
superintendent calls numerous fatalities
now we have new a number of unconfirmed
numbers we're not going to throw those
out there right now but multiple
fatalities is what we're hearing from
officials at this moment the suspect is
in custody in fact being transported now
you're looking live on the scene Phil
Keating is on the scene right now with
the very latest could even Phil
good evening Brett good stay absolutely
catastrophic in the words of the Broward
County Sheriff Scott Israel who perhaps
within 15 minutes is expected to come
out here and update the media on this
horriffic day in Broward County
especially for the families of what have
been confirmed by multiple people as
multiple fatalities we just don't know
the full total number at this point
often the distance you can see we are
just about a quarter of a mile from the
high school Marjory Stoneman Douglas
high school a school of for grades three
thousand students described as your
everyday American high school by
students one I've spoken with well you
have the bomb squad down there
the FBI mobile command center is down
there hundreds of law enforcement
vehicles are here and no traffic can't
get closer to the high school at nearby
hotels and elementary schools that is
where some of the evacuated students
have been taken to rendezvous with their
parents in a very panic filled past
three to four hours this afternoon all
of this happening around 4:00 or 2:30
Eastern Time
right as the school day was just about
to end helicopter aerials provided by
our Miami Fox affiliate WSVN showing
students running for their lives into
safety with backpacks still on from the
school out through the parking lots
reminiscent of what we saw back in the
90s at the Columbine High School
massacre in Littleton Colorado
the suspect was arrested within about an
hour and 15 minutes by law enforcement
just about a mile and a half away from
the high school and he has been named
according to the Associated Press citing
an unnamed federal official as Nicholas
Cruz 18 years old described as a former
student of the high school but not a
current students and some reports from
students inside the school at the time
of the shooting were that the alarm had
been pulled for a regularly scheduled
fire drill allure that day and around
2:30 p.m. that is when this suspected
shooter pulled the alarm and then
started shooting students as they fled
the classrooms to run down the hallways
and so we do believe inside that school
there are casualties that remain on the
ground on what is going to be an
enormous crime scene some of the most
tear felt moments came this afternoon
when the Broward County Schools
Superintendent Robert rincey spoke about
what he knew and what he saw at that
moment take a listen can't confirm the
number at this point but there are
fatalities involved you tell us at least
how many transports did you know it may
be a dozen I don't know the number
that's been transported at this point
but again there there are numerous
fatalities it's a horrific situation
students and teachers inside the school
at the time of the shooting had told law
enforcement that the suspected shooter
was wearing a black hat burgundy shirt
black pants and that was in fact the
exact outfit that was being worn by the
suspect handcuffed and taken into
custody
that suspect ID this Nicholas Cruz 18
years old was then taken to a nearby
hospital for treatment we don't know
exactly what the extent of his injuries
are but according to students who were
inside the schools they have of course
heard about school shootings throughout
their young lives but they said what
happened here today was really
unimaginable take a listen I was praying
to God thinking that
he could save us on that
I cope me periods of the might if it's
just so crazy like all you could think
about is oh my God my family my friends
everything like you never think it would
happen to you but it does and as all of
this was still unfolding and police
officers and SWAT teams were going
classroom to classroom clearing them out
releasing the students to safety outside
of the building it was truly an
unimaginable day as well for elected
leaders the governor the president both
tweeting out comments and releasing
statements expressing their grief and
condolences to the families involved
Governor Rick Scott of Florida is on his
way down here and should be arriving on
the scene very soon here to be here in
person tonight and Senator Bill Nelson
spoke with our Shepard Smith this
afternoon live on the air and one of two
Florida senators and he said basically
he just seriously laments the fact that
he is once again responding to yet
another school shooting take a listen
our heart goes out to the families of
students the school they're grieving
I have already said my prayers to give
them comfort but this is a tough time
again we are expecting Broward County
Sheriff Scott Israel who last was
appearing on national TV last year at
the floor
Fort Lauderdale International Airport at
that horrible crime scene where the man
opened fire in the baggage carrousel
area he was a very on point and on the
scene sheriff here in Broward County
Florida so we are expecting him here
hopefully within the half-hour again it
is Valentine's Day and some of the
students first interviewed by local
media this morning said you know we
heard pop pop hop we thought they were
Valentine's Day balloons being popped by
students because there were numerous
Valentine's Day parties inside the high
school today and unfortunately those
turned out to be not the sounds of
balloons Brett but the sounds of gunfire
yeah fill the students telling the story
from inside the classroom and trying to
get out of that school as authorities
were trying to get them out a couple of
more students talking to our local
affiliate down there a tickle ism
don't have those sound bites yet Phil
but I want to ask you a question the
shooter is believed to have gone to that
school and 18 years old but had some
history about talking about showing
pictures of guns according to trace
Gallagher getting that from authorities
down there yep
yeah and that was also coming from a
student at the school being interviewed
by our SVN Fox Miami affiliate saying he
knew who the kid was he had been at an
alternative school with him in years
past didn't like to associate with the
guy because they thought the guy may
have been trouble showing him cellphone
photos of his guns and according to our
trace Gallagher and the Los Angeles
grouchy europium today this suspect had
a social media history of looking at gun
friendly and bomb friendly websites